rules president Pedro Castillo has been
arrested on charges of rebellion and
conspiracy after being ousted by
Congress Castillo had earlier tried to
dissolve parliament and install an
emergency government hours before he was
to face an impeachment vote now Peru's
former vice president Dina Boulevard has
been sworn in as president she's the
first woman to lead the country
tear gas and turmoil in Lima after a day
packed with political drama
it began early in the morning with Pedro
Castillo's announcement that he was
dissolving Parliament ahead of its third
attempt to impeach him since he took
office in 2021
his announcement spot demonstrations on
the streets Mass resignations from his
government and Defiance from the
opposition-dominated Congress
it moved up the impeachment vote which
passed with only six votes against
vice president Gina barbote was sworn in
as Peru's first female president shortly
after in her first speech to Parliament
she didn't mince words about Castillo's
removal
there has been an attempted coup d'etat
an attempt promoted by Pedro Castillo
which has not found an audience in the
institutions of democracy and on the
streets
in Lima many demonstrators backed his
removal
CEO is trying to run away from Justice
he's opted for the last resort trying to
dissolve the Congress
but supporters of Castillo whose 17
turbulent months in power were marked by
five cabinets six criminal
investigations and two earlier failed
impeachment attempts were Furious
[Music]
from the beginning president Pedro
Castillo has not been allowed to work
president Castillo has been slandered
that's why we're going through what
we're going through now and why this
corrupt Congress needed to be dissolved
he was elected by all the Peruvian
people not just Lima the people of the
whole country the whole of Peru and they
have to learn to respect the will of the
people
Castilla who left the presidential
Palace after being removed from office
has been arrested and charged with
rebellion and conspiracy if convicted he
could face years in prison
tws Latin America correspondent Nicole
Reese spoke to us earlier about the
latest political twists and turns in
Peru
it was one last attempt to cling to
power but instead ex-president Pedro
Castillo has managed to put himself in a
much worse situation committing
political suicide and allowing Congress
to go after what they have been wanting
for for months now basically replacing
him Pedro Castillo's presidency has been
marked with the accusation of corruption
which is also why he had lost so many
votes and so much confidence among his
own people now that it is not president
anymore he has also lost the immunity
that he once enjoyed and will sooner or
later have to face trial in connection
to these accusations in the meantime
peruvians have to face another political
crisis and most of them a majority would
like to see fresh elections in order to
be able to decide what is best for the
country and where Peru is heading